people all across this great nation
are in pain they have hard
lives are you still sore i can't work
here no more
it'll be all right and we
have the cure this new miracle drug
oxycontin you will be the largest
sales force in pharmaceutical history
make your doctors feel
special take them to expensive dinners
bribe the receptionist with a mani-pedi
whatever it takes
to win their trust your most effective
talking point are
these magic words less than one percent
of people get addicted to oxycontin
that's not possible
i can't live like this anymore i'll
start you on this
call on a miracle drug you only take two
a day
i think i can make this the biggest drug
in the world
i think maybe that medicine might be
just a tad more addictive than you said
that's not what we're hearing something
is happening here
there might be a unique situation
brewing
a pharma company is lying about their
medication
we have to go after the makers of
oxycontin
my patients trusted me i can't believe
how many of them
are good now
we're gonna do everything in our power
to make sure justice is served
we're going to cure the world
of its pain
you